this year the Board of Governors of the
Academy has voted a special award for
makeup I don't quite understand why they
asked me to make this presentation
because I don't wear any make a little
pinch on the cheeks bring out the color
moisten my lips and I'm ready to face
the work of course there is makeup and
then again there is makeup with John
Chambers please come out here and get
his award
mr. chambers is responsible for making
monkeys out of Roddy McDowall Morris
Evans and Kim hunter the Planet of the
Apes
and quite brilliantly too will one of
the friends of Oscar back there please
bring mr. chambers his Warren
that's what I call a terrific makeup job
how can I follow an act like that may I
thank the Board of Governors for this
wonderful honor may thank mr. zanuck mr.
Jacobs and Ben Nye and dance tree Peck
who share this award with me I say but
most of all all those wonderful makeup
men and hairstyles that worked so hard
to make this picture a success from all
of us to all of you god bless you and
thank you so much